مبادلة الطائرة هو مشروع رائع للغاية ، سنقوم
بتشغيل طائرتين ،
سأطير بأحدهما وأطير بالطائرة الأخرى ، ولا يرتفع أي شخص آخر
فيها إلى ارتفاع يصل إلى 12 13000 قدم ، ضعها
في نقطة غوص ، تنطلق الخطط على
الأرض منها  كل طائرة تقوم بتبديل الطائرات التي سأركبها
في طائرته ، سوف يدخل في خطتي ،
لذا أقلع في واحدة وهبط في أخرى ،
إنها المرة الثانية التي قفزت فيها
مع المطار ، يمكنك رؤية الطائرة
تتحرك قليلاً
حولنا  أتحقق من الأمر ،
لذا فأنت في الواقع تقفز بالمظلات بطائرة على
الرغم من اتباعك لهذه
العلامة الحمراء
[موسيقى]
آه كنت أعمل بالفعل مع كيربي
رياضي آخر من ريد بول
وذهبنا إلى سباق وقالوا مرحبًا الرجل
الذي قفز
بدون المظلة هنا
ورياضي ريد بول الذي تعرفه قلت
جيدًا أريدك أن تقابل هذا الرجل لأنه
مجنون وشجاع ،
جلسنا على طاولة وعلى
منديل ورسم بعض مكابح السرعة
على أجنحة أنت تعرف  كيف يمكننا القيام
بذلك من أجلي فإن التحدي لا
يتعلق بالسرعة أو g  o مرتفعًا أو بطيئًا ، فإن
مشروع مبادلة الطائرة خلف الكواليس بالنسبة لي
يتعلق بتعلم المزيد من الأشياء للقيام بأشياء
لم أفعلها من قبل وهذا ما
يجعله مثيرًا للاهتمام بالنسبة لي
أنه سيصنع تاريخ الطيران
من نواح كثيرة
ولكن الشيء الأكبر هو  عدم وجود أي
طيارين في الطائرة وتبديل
الطائرات ، حيث قام الأشخاص بطيران الطائرات على
الأرض من قبل في
تكوينات مختلفة وما إلى ذلك ،
ولكن في هذا واحد سيكون مجرد الحصول على
استراحة كبيرة للمساعدة في إبطاء الطائرة
وتبديل الطائرات التي سنطير
بها مثل  هذا حتى الطائرة
، سنمسك دعامة الجناح ثم نسير في
طريقنا مباشرة إلى الطائرة
وبمجرد أن يصل جسمك إلى منتصف الطريق في
الباب ، لا توجد رياح ، سيكون كل شيء على ما يرام
سيكون بإمكانك قلب المفاتيح
واستعادة الطائرة ، أعد تشغيل المحرك ،
اسحب فرامل السرعة
وأعدها للهبوط
[موسيقى] ،
لذلك عندما كنت طفلاً كنت أقوم بطائرات RC
كثيرًا أحب أنني نشأت في
مطار خاص كان والدي  طيار
رر  آيرز في البحرية ، كل جدي ،
جعلنا جميعًا نطير ، لذا أخذت نموذج RC
وخرجت واشتريت واحدة
كانت نسخة سيسنا ، أعني
نفس الشيء تقريبًا الذي كنت أبحث عنه
مع 182 وقمنا ببناء  كسر المقياس
في الأسفل وبدأنا في الطيران ،
فهذه هي الصورة التي ألهمت
كل شيء عندما كنت طفلاً صغيراً ، آه
في المدرسة الثانوية ، ظهرت هذه الصورة
في مجلة هذه هي الصورة بالضبط
من المجلة ولكن الطائرة من النوع المناسب
مثل التعلق من مظلة
ولذا أخذت هذه
الفكرة وفكرة التبديل التجريبي
بدلاً من القفز فقط وجعلها
تعلم أن الانتقال إلى المستوى التالي كان نوعًا
ما طوال حياتي أخذ الأشياء إلى
المستوى التالي لذلك هذا هو  رائع حقًا
لدمج الطائرة التي تحلق كما لو
كانت مصممة للطيران ،
ليس لدينا مظلات خارجية أو
أي شيء نسحب الفرامل
وتطير الطائرة وتهبط بشكل طبيعي ولكن
هذا هو ما ألهمك
[موسيقى]